okay so it's time to start our session
today the first stop is by Constantine
karma is about high dimensional robots
parse progression
thanks very much and thanks to the to
the organizers for Lauren for organizing
and also for inviting me so this is a
talk and a theme of something that I've
been interested in for quite a long time
and give you a little bit of the history
of what you know what's been done and
what are some recent breakthroughs and
and also why this is an interesting an
interesting problem this is joint work
with with three PhD students at UT
Leeloo Yaya Chen and in Ken young Lee so
start with just a brief overview here
what is what is the general problem I'm
interested in because of the work
because the word robust is used in a
number of a number of different settings
but so I'm given the problem I'm
interested in is how I get data and what
I mean by this is that you know almost
all of the data about a constant
fraction or come from some model P which
I care about and then and then an
epsilon fraction which is an order one
fraction comes from some arbitrary
distribution that an adversary can
select the adversary can select it even
after seeing potentially the realization
of the data so it's a it's a and and the
adversary has no computational or or
otherwise of restrictions the adversary
can also know whatever algorithm you're
going to use and the goal is to estimate
some parameters of this original
distribution so this is the this is the
basic problem you know now there as I
mentioned you know robust statistics has
a has has a long history now I guess the
fancier word the neural networks word
for this is data poisoning so we always
have to keep coming up with with new
terms to to keep things fresh and
exciting so the key idea that you should
have in mind is you want to find the
mean of a bunch of numbers and but
there's been some outliers at it okay so
I'm going to come back to this example
because even
it's very simple and we all know what we
should what we should do here it's
illustrative and fides
if we look at it in the right way it can
provide the key of what we should do in
the in a high dimensional setting whoops
I guess we just restart in this case
right
let's see if that worked
seems like it did yeah so this has been
a classical problem in in statistics
that has a very long long history even
to the first part of the of the 20th
century but the focus here was not on
things that respect that most of the
most of the results in the traditional
literature have been asymptotic in
nature and not really focused on
problems that demand very careful
attention to computational complexity
and in fact there's been very little
progress until recently even from really
basic problems so when I mean basic
problems I mean things like mean
estimation in high dimensions or
regression estimating say top singular
vector of the data let's see so if the
adversary has to commit to cue and then
you get to draw iid samples I think that
would would also be challenging I'm not
sure how how that would make my results
better in this particular case so the
adversary can even do even do that in
fact some of the results that I'll
mention have look at an even stronger
model where the adversary where the data
are drawn the adversary gets to delete
some of them so even the authentic
samples are no longer iid according to
the to the distribution but that's not
the model that I and I will look at so
just to give up for those that don't
know about this area until pretty
recently even the problem of estimating
say the top singular vector of the top
principal component of data in this
regime where the number of samples
scales approximately like the dimension
which is the regime that we we would
care about if we're if we have a simple
Gaussian covariance estimation problem
think about the spiked covariance model
this is this is really the regime of
of interest we don't have samples way
more than that
the the situation until until few years
ago was stark in the sense that there
was no as far as I know polynomial time
algorithm that even could guarantee a
positive breakdown point so in robust
statistics this concept of breakdown
point is not even trying to give a
specific guarantee it's just saying an
algorithms break the breakdown point is
is the epsilon we're beyond that an
algorithm can't guarantee basically
anything better than guessing so it's so
it's it means that the algorithm has no
no guarantees whatsoever so basically
this is not good so it's a challenging
than the challenging problem yes yeah
well okay so in this case I'm thinking
of the of the easy problem where I let's
say I want to do where I want to
estimate to the spike in a spike
covariance model yes so it's that kind
of problem but but yeah D log D I just
mean I don't have n so much bigger than
D that I could apply a one-dimensional
estimator say to each each component and
then to be able to convert say and
infinity-norm confound into on each of
the individual entries into something
like an operator something looks
something like something like that
okay so there's been there's been
progress since here but I'm just just
setting the stage here and let me give
you an idea of like why high dimensions
is really or this dimensional regime is
what's what's important to look at so
the classical picture that we think
about maybe if I if you haven't thought
about robust pca you think okay i have
i've got this cloud of points
what could the adversary do with just a
few points to really mess me up and you
see that this is really the only thing
the adversary can can do in the in this
low dimensional setting low dimensional
because i have many many more points
than than dimensions so the adversary
would be forced to do that and and
and so if we think about you know the
approach here that you would take here
is just to pre-process your data you can
you know realize that these points are
farther away you could compute some
Mahalanobis distance or there's a whole
host of things that you can do and these
are in the classical text books on
robust pca from 30-40 years ago but okay
this is my best attempt to draw in high
dimensions but you know here if you're
if you're sampling from a high
dimensional Gaussian and you your
samples are approximately the same as
the number of dimensions you basically
every single point is on its own
essentially perpendicular to every other
point and also perpendicular to the
direction that you wish to recover so
it's it's very easy the adversary
doesn't have to do something like this
doesn't really have to reveal reveal
itself the adversary can just put some
points they don't even have to be that
far away they don't have to be higher in
magnitude so this is why it's harder the
problem is harder and interesting in
high dimensions there's no real
pre-processing that you can that you can
do the only thing that actually reveals
that the presence of an adversary is if
you sort of if you know the solution
already because the solution would fit
the majority of your points but not fit
be the outliers so it's a
chicken-and-egg problem in this way so
this is why a lot of interesting things
so III as I mentioned I've been um you
know been at it for a while and so it's
almost 10 years ago now we with my
colleague Quan shoe and Shimon or
basically what we worked on this problem
and found an algorithm that'll tell you
a little bit later that that basically
has a break down point 50 percent which
is you can see is the best possible if
you're committed to outputting only a
single solution if your adversary
controls more than 50 percent of your
data there's really nothing that you can
do so so this algorithm
guarantees that you'll recover something
that's better than guessing even even if
you have 51% of the data are not
corrupted this is some early early work
on on the covariance estimation problem
there was a lot of work on robust
regression starting around the same time
where there was only only allowed
corruptions in the output so I have my
my covariance and this is the this is
it's called the dependent variable so if
you're only allowed to corrupt the
labels there's a lot of work that used
essentially technology from sparse
recovery and treated but the the
corruptions constant fraction of
corruptions essentially like a sparse
like a sparse variable to be detected
and using ideas from from from sparse
recovery things like algorithms like
glass so essentially and and then
concepts like our IP restricted
eigenvalue conditions and so on were
able to show these we're able to show
that that you can deal with this quite
well but in the setting where you have
corruptions in X&Y things seem to be
much more much more difficult in fact
than in this paper we showed that no
convex method or in any case of that
convex methods are fundamentally unable
to deal with corruptions in X&Y though
they are able to deal with corruptions
in Y that's what these works here use
essentially a convex formulation and are
able to to be resilient to a constant
fraction of corruptions and why but
that's that's that whole host of
approaches where you have a convex loss
function and maybe a convex regularizer
no combination of those is is able to
work for a fundamental reason but we
weren't able to do much much better than
then than them here we're only able to
show that through different algorithms
not based on convex optimization where
we could be resilient to a sub linear
fraction of corruptions in x and y so I
can't say that we're resilient to say 2%
corruptions or 1
percent of the data being being
corrupted oh that was the best that we
could we could do at that point and then
of course there have been a lot of other
works that deal with different forms of
corruption that are pretty different
from this talk so I want to at least
mention that there's an entire line of
work that deals with for example sparse
corruptions to a low rank matrix trying
to recover those those two components so
that's what these two works are now
about ten years old and then there's
been a huge follow but this is very
different from this yeah good point so
you're asking perhaps what maybe the
problem is unidentifiable for example
but is that oh no no no yeah
no no so so if you run PCA or you run
just ordinary least-squares and you just
have even a vanishing fraction like I
order one number of just a constant
number of about Liars
you can Don you can have it can be
arbitrarily bad and this by the way is
also true because of its high
dimensional settings so you know this
this this picture if you just take one
point and align it with one of the are
one of arbitrary points there's so much
energy in having two points that are
aligned when every other point is close
to perpendicular to every other point
that even just that would if you ran PCA
it would basically pick out whatever
direction that you as you wanted okay so
more more recent history here has made
significant progress especially
significant progress on what we had been
able to do here where we were able to
guarantee that you have a breakdown
point that's almost 50 percent but we
didn't really have strong guarantees on
how well you could do yeah we have some
guarantees on how well you could do but
but these have been significantly
improved and and what I'll talk about
today really leverages that progress
that was really what we've unlocked all
a lot of a lot of possibilities so and
and you can see that this happened very
recently just a just a few years ago
there was work on a robust mean
estimation and even more recently this
has been followed up I think I haven't
seen Artie but maybe I think she was one
of the she's one of the organizers of
this session so she's this is this is
her on and on robust sparse mean
estimation so what is this what is this
problem robust mean estimation you get a
bunch of data and D dimensions and you
don't know nothing about the mean
there's nothing no structure about the
mean so you're willing to get samples
proportional to D but robust sparse mean
estimation is what it sounds like you
have data and D dimensions but most of
the entries of the mean are are 0 so you
would like to have sub linear sample
complexity and and and there's been you
know lots of work on this so Hopkins who
who actually is a Miller postdoc here in
September posted posted some recent work
on on the load on the low dimensional
setting on Monday these authors posted
something on Tuesday at Hopkins posted
an update I was hoping to give a talk
later today just in case I'd be able to
report more more progress so this is an
active area and lots of things have have
been happening and importantly this is
that this has been some enabling
enabling and in my view for for some
more general approaches to robust
statistics and also robust regression
which is what I'm going to talk about
the most related paper probably to what
to what I'm going to talk about is work
that happened also it also in this year
on using some of these techniques for
robust regression but but not in the
sparse setting so I should also mention
there's another there's another line of
work that I'm not going to talk about
because the techniques are not are not
related to what we're going to use that
use of the sum of squares to
knology to build algorithms that are
that are resilient to two outliers
okay so let me tell you but again
specifically what what the model is a
time that I'm thinking about so I'm
thinking about this the standard sparse
regression model where I the number of
samples I have is much less than the
number of dimensions and I would like
the number of samples to scale ideally
like sparsity log D we're gonna need for
reasons that I'll explain sparse to be
squared logs but but that would be our
goal to really have something that's
carrot scales sparse to do log D because
we know that in the uncorrupted model in
by now it's very well-studied that as
long as as long as as long as you're
sensing matrix satisfies some properties
that convex algorithms like lasso or a
number of different a number of
different approaches can can succeed in
recovering recovering beta so so this is
this is well known and this is what we
aspire aspire to so I guess this was
your this is your question you know
single corrupted sample can can really
make your life bad if you if you ignore
if you ignore it and just run the
standard out for my good data so the
authentic points this is my P I had a P
and a Q and this is my 1 minus epsilon
fraction of the points come from from
this from this model
good question yeah so uh my model my
matrix X in this work is going to be
drawn from a Gaussian standard Gaussian
so that basically best-case best-case
scenario that's that's right so X by
itself has a distribution of a standard
Gaussian and then the distribution of Y
is is going to come from this
multiplication by a sparse vector plus
additive noise that's independent that's
right yeah this is this a standard
standard regression model and P is what
I so P is what I care about and then Q
is something just arbitrary and epsilon
is that is what I would want to be a
constant fraction of of my outlier so it
can be small but but but I don't want it
to be to be vanishing it guess so this
is actually now the model that I have so
the the top part of the matrix comes
from my model P and then the bottom part
is completely arbitrary and it's not
just these labels that are flipped so
just flipping labels as I mentioned we
can address using other techniques
basically variations on lasso will do a
really good job but but those fail and
as I mentioned there's fundamental
reasons that they that they fail it's
not that it's not due to not clever
enough tuning or something like that
where if you where if X is also
corrupted then then we need to think
about something different
okay so back again showing related work
so these are some of the works that I
mentioned that that could deal with
corruptions only in Y and the much more
recent work is able to deal with with
when I say low-dimensional again I I
just mean that I'm allowed to have
samples that are proportional to the
number of dimensions that I have well I
say high dimensional I mean that I have
sparsity and because of sparse today I'm
going to insist on having my samples
scale sub linearly logarithmically in
the in the in the ambient dimension and
we had been an attempt to sometime ago
but we were really only able to get this
sub linear sub linear fraction of resist
resilience to sub linear fraction of of
corruptions okay so this is the brief
summary of work on robust regression so
far so the low dimensional setting we
basically know what to do there and in
the high dimensional setting we don't we
sort of have an idea have sub linear
scaling which is really much much weaker
than what what is possible in the low
dimensional setting I mentioned the sum
of squares technology the sum of squares
technology fits into this line here I
don't see a fundamental reason why that
couldn't that wouldn't work for the for
the sparsity as well but I think that
that hasn't done so I don't know that
I'm not saying that that can't be done
but I hasn't been done and I don't know
how to I haven't thought about that
so which so we really don't know we have
essentially until now we have what I
would say is a pretty weak compared to
the two low dimensional regression
result about about sparse regression
with outliers when when the the
variables are when X is is corrupted as
well now on the other hand the the
Kenickie result so we're gonna use come
from robust mean estimation and robust
sparse mean estimation and I'll explain
how these how these work because this is
really what is the enabling technology
or what I'll show you and also this the
the previous work on low-dimensional on
the low dimensional setting
okay so again this I guess this is my
summary again event of what uh what we
of what we know okay so our idea is
since we know how to do robust sparse
mean estimation then let's think about
an algorithm that an iterative algorithm
that can leverage robust sparse mean
estimation this is the main tool so if
you think about any problem in empirical
risk any empirical risk minimization
problem and think about gradient descent
at every step what you're doing is your
gradient is a sum of gradients each one
coming from a different data point so if
I have if ten percent of those are
corrupted then I at every step of
gradient descent I'm trying to find the
average of data ten percent of which are
corrupted so that's this is the key
thought that okay so now we've learned
that thanks to those other papers that I
mentioned how to do robust robust mean
estimation let me just apply that in do
gradient descent okay so this was the
idea in in the 2018 paper that I mention
that does a low dimensional setting
basically they apply they apply robust
mean estimation in the setting where to
the gradient it at each at each step but
now I I can't afford to do that because
even though we know algorithms like if I
did gradient descent on lasso under the
nice assumptions that I have such as my
authentic data coming from a Gaussian I
know that that would converge without
without outliers that would converge to
the to the true solution but the path
doesn't always stay on the set of sparse
vectors the path would go through
potentially dense vectors so if I'm
hoping to do robust gradient estimation
at every time I am estimating something
that's not that the gradients are not
going to be sparse if I'm if I'm doing
gradient descent so that would so this
this agenda would this program would
work but I would have to use general
robust mean estimation which means that
I would need way more samples than
that I'm willing to that I'm willing to
use so if I want to use robust mean
sparse mean estimation we need to use
some approach that maintains sparsity of
every level and the natural thought is
is to basically apply a Thresh floating
operator at every time hard thresholding
operator to make sure that I maintain
sparsity along the entire the entire
trajectory and this and this
accomplishes this accomplishes that the
reason that one sparsity is our the main
tool that I'm gonna use is at at every
level when I at every point when I want
to find my new direction I need to find
the gradient I need to use some I need
that up and that gradient is going to be
an average of the gradients at every
single point some of those are corrupted
so I want to I want to kind of come up
with a robust estimate of that but I
want one on estimating to be sparse so
that I don't have to use samples
proportional to dimension I want to use
fewer samples so I need that that thing
to be to be sparse okay so basically
this this is the I is a simple idea and
what you need to show here is two things
you need to show that you can do robust
sparse mean estimation on the gradients
and you need to show also then that you
need to show that that iterative heart
threshold thing is stable okay so these
are and these are separate in the sense
that if you can show that iterative
heart threshold is stable meaning that
if there are some error at every stage
then you can control your error of the
output then basically you can anybody
who comes up with a robust sparse mean
estimate that works on on the gradients
you could you can plug those in so those
are those are separate those are
separate parts okay so what we and what
we do is basically follow out this
agenda so so we show that that IHT is
stable so this means that if you have a
robust sparse gradient estimate I had to
I had to use some acronym here so if you
have a robust sparse gradient estimate
that is promised as a particular error
then our result tells you that if you
just plug that directly into IHT you you
what kind of error will this suffer in
the end of the at the end of the day
there's something so I'll describe two
different two different procedures one
is an ellipsoid based algorithm look
that that's used for for a robust as far
as granion estimate we explain a little
bit how how that works that basically
requires quite a bit of computation so
then I'll improve that basically by by
an order of the dimension so an order
wise faster using a different different
robust sparse mean estimation algorithm
so basically there's two parts to these
results the first is giving a faster by
a factor of D which is the dimension
robust parse mean estimate estimation
algorithm and then also showing that any
robust sparse gradient estimate
estimation algorithm if you plug it into
ihd it would give you if you tell me
what your what your guarantees are on
your your RS GE then I'll tell you what
what error you're gonna have for for
iterative hard brush holding
okay so it's interesting to think about
what you know what what what goes into
these ideas of a robust mean and
covariance estimation and it's helpful
to think about the really simple problem
of the mean versus the trimmed mean the
median and ask why that why that works
and basically one way to think about
this is that if if I have a Gaussian and
I want to estimate its mean this is just
in one dimension and you throw in a
bunch of and you and you want to throw
in some points to confuse me if I say 10
percent of the points if I tell you that
I'm gonna throw away 10 percent of the
points and it'll be the biggest 10
percent of the points what are you going
to do well you basically can either put
huge points to try to screw me up but
they're gonna be thrown away by the
trimmed mean so that's not a very good
idea or you're going to have to you're
going to basically be forced to put the
points in very close to the to the true
mean which might somewhat confuse me but
won't confuse me very much and the
high-level idea here is that what we're
doing with trimmed mean trimmed mean
again just means that you throw away
that 10% largest largest points so what
the reason that trim demean works is
that for a distribution like the
Gaussian if I remove the points that
contribute most to my estimator in this
case the mean it doesn't actually affect
the mean very much so when you throw
away the biggest points those are the
points that are contributing most to
your calculation of the mean it's not
the small points that contribute most
but because of because of the way the
Gaussian is most of the this doesn't
actually affect your calculation of the
mean on the other hand if you're only
allowed to add ten percent of the points
you're that you're the you're the
conniving adversary and you put the
points very far away trimmed mean is is
awful for you so this is the yes yes
that's that's right but for this result
you don't need you don't need it to be
actually you can do slightly better if
it's fear achill but you if it's
controlled then yeah then then you can
do this all the same story so basically
how this this concept of how we remove
points that contribute most and then use
only the remaining points is another key
thread that that links all of these
papers together they're done in slightly
slightly different ways but but this is
the this is the key one of the key ideas
that makes me and estimation Co variance
estimation possible even when when you
have outliers it's this the simple idea
that works for trim mean so more
concretely here the idea is that you
remove some fraction of the data and
remove could be actually remove or some
soft version where you just down weight
so that the first and second moments
satisfy a certain property and I'll tell
you some examples of this so you so you
so so you can get a flavor of how all of
it essentially all of these results
where they come from okay so back to the
mean what what is this property that is
satisfied so you have you have a hundred
points and you know the ten of them are
corrupted so if you remove ten and you
find out that the remaining ninety the
remaining subset has a similar mean and
trimmed mean this is a really good
indication for you that you removed the
the bed the bad points so in other words
if you if ninety points come from a
Gaussian if I have a hundred points and
ninety of them come from a Gaussian and
I find those and I look at those ninety
points and I compare the mean of the
ninety points and the mean of the of the
eighty points after I throw away that
the the 10 percent biggest those two
numbers are pretty close and that's that
that is a property that it basically
certifies that the points that you have
don't have really really bad outliers
it's this so this idea of basically
checking to see if if your remaining
points the ones that you didn't remove
or the ones that you didn't down weight
satisfies certain property this idea is
used in different in different versions
so for example in our older work on
covariance estimation that's the
property that we used it was very
similar to this to this concept from the
mean basically you say that you know if
I if I have a candidate principle
component and I project all my data onto
there if the if if the variance of those
points is close to the variance if I
trim 10% of them I'm using 10% as my
stand-in for epsilon then you know that
you found a really good then you know
that you found a good direction so so
other work uses um some similar against
the concept is the concept is similar so
in in in these two works this they used
they don't throw away points they use a
soft they down wait points and the
property that they have is that a
particular second moment has small
enough operator norm and you know that
it has to have small operator norm
because of some assumptions of the
problem this is like side these require
this side information so basically the
deviation of the second of second moment
from some side information is small
enough that's a property that certifies
similarly to this property that's a
property that certifies that your
remaining samples are down weighted
samples that you have are that you've
successfully down weighted or removed
outliers so this property of things
remain the same when you remove trim
part and then when you remove the
extremes relies heavily on the sandwich
distribution right it definitely relies
on properties the distribution yeah
that's that you have to know yeah that's
correct yeah
okay so give you more details here so
basically the the way that these are
these are the results that we use the
way that these work is that they show
that if you have a deviation in the mean
does the mean is what we want to
estimate this this implies that you have
a deviation in a particular calculation
of a second of a second moment and and
what these results do is they say okay
I'm going to basically if I detect if I
detect that that I have a large
deviation in the second moment then they
use an ellipsoid algorithm over the set
of weights to find a way to improve to
find a way to improve the the weights
and down weight points away from away
from the outliers so this requires using
a lip sort algorithm which which forces
you to do a lot of iterations and this
is one way we're we're where we have a
we can improve this this setting so how
much time do I do I have eight minutes
okay okay so where does where does the
sparsity play in here and also where do
our distributional assumptions play and
that they play in a pretty important in
a pretty important way so so this is
what iterative heart threshold because
it computes it computes the gradient and
then it and then it thresholds it PK is
just keep the top K top K components so
if you compute what the what the
gradient is because of our
distributional assumptions the expected
gradient over just authentic data not
over my corrupted data is exactly going
to be my current iterate minus the
optimal solution and this is something
that's sparse because I'm always fresh
holding and because my assumption is
that I'm trying to recover something
that's sparse then the difference of
these also is going to be sparse the
worst case it'll be twice the number of
non-zeros but it will still be it
still be sparse so you can see here this
kind of lays bare where the where the
distributional assumptions play play a
very important role and also why I need
to make sure that all along my
trajectory
I'm sparse because if I were just using
something like say lasso then there is
no reason that my my a turret would be
sparse and so even under these
distributional assumptions there is no
reason that the gradient that you're
trying to compute would be needs to be
needs to be sparse so this is in my
opinion is is extremely limiting that's
where we are right now and you can see
that it's that that is important because
if I if instead of the identity here if
I have an arbitrary covariance matrix
then that will potentially destroy my
sparsity but this is this is something
that we're we're working on and this is
something that's needed if you would
like if you want to consider interesting
problems like let's say basically like
like a graphical model estimation
problem you really you're gonna have a
covariance matrix that's not that's
that's not gonna look like like that so
this is an important um important thing
to deal with so you also want to
maintain you sparsity step at each step
that's right so I want to be sparse at
each step I want to be sparse in
expectation over the good samples of
each step because what that's saying is
that my so this is my this is my
algorithm this is what I need to
estimate and some of these are corrupt
and some of them are not and I and I
know that the expected value of these
the non-core the the non corrupt the
expected value of the gradients
GI is a gradient of each point the
expected value over only the the
distribution of of authentic points has
this form
so you know if you sparse at each step
you know can't good guys and you
insulate yourself okay it's the bad guy
yeah so if I'm sports that you just you
might get affected by them even at the
solution at the end of a spark that's so
I need to be I need to know that in
expectation I'm sparse my update in
expectation is sparse at each step
because that means that what I'm
basically trying to estimate the sparse
mean of a bunch of vectors that's that's
that's the reason because the key
technology that I'm using is this robust
sparse mean estimator so yeah so that so
that that is that that's really
important that that's credibly here okay
so basically let's see what I want to
what I have time to tell you about the
oh the ellipsoid algorithm
I mentioned that it essentially computes
deviation around around a particular so
the side information that that gives of
the key property that I mentioned for
for for the ellipsoid algorithm is that
you should be concentrating around
around this around this matrix and you
can compute deviations second-order
deviations away from that and that that
basically certifies whether or not your
mean estimate is good or whether or
whether it's not and how to improve and
okay so there's a lot here that I'm not
providing details but I do want to say
that the the key idea in this in in this
paper in this in this paper is that if
in order to convert the ellipsoid
algorithm to work for for sparse mean
estimation then it's enough to just
check second moments not only I don't
need to check the deviation of the
second moment from this matrix only sub
matrices so I need to basically look at
all of the I need to look at how sparse
not sparse but all sub matrices K by K
sub matrices of the second moment how
those deviate and that is exactly a
sparse PCA problem so I want so
basically if you if you want to compute
an operator norm but only over vectors
that have K'naan zeros this is this is
fundamentally the the spar sub the
sparse PCA problem and so the main idea
is showing that even under that in this
setting convex relaxations to this to
the sparse PCA problem are good enough
to detect this to detect this this
deviation and to tell you how to improve
your your weights so this is essentially
what this what this says this is this is
a this is the convex relaxation just
parse PCA and the key result that's
telling us that if this value is small
that's like a certificate that you found
that that the your estimate of the mean
is is good enough and if it's big it
tells you it gives you a separation and
to separate it serves as a separation
Oracle and tells you how to down weight
the weights and you can you do this you
can you can use this technology using
essentially the ellipsoid algorithm so
that's that is that in a nutshell but
you need to basically you need
dimensions squared calls in order to run
the ellipsoid algorithm with a generic
separation separation Oracle so guess
how so basically instead of instead of
that you can get rid of a dimension a
factor of D and make only D calls by
instead of working over soft with soft
weights you actually just discard
discard points so I think I'll skip the
the details there it basically the idea
is just you get a score for each point
and then you just throw points away
randomly according to those according to
those weights so and then you can show
that if you do this enough basically
using kind of martingale techniques you
can show that if you have epsilon
fraction of points then if you do that
many iterations exactly and how many you
would expect you you have thrown away
all the outliers that actually affect
your estimate
possibly some outliers remain that don't
affect your estimate but you don't duh
you don't care about about those okay so
basically putting all of these things
together this let's come back to the the
overall agenda of iterative part thrush
holding plus some robust sparse grading
estimate so this what this result says
this is the this is the Mehta theorem
that basically says that if you have a
robust sparse grading estimate of
quality whatever it is so you tell me
you you're the person who came up with
that and you just give me the guarantees
of your robust parse grading estimate
then if you run IHT using that as a
subroutine and at every step
then the guarantees the error guarantees
that you have are basically the square
root of whatever guarantees you had for
your for the squared deviation of your
of your gradient so this is essentially
saying that you don't accumulate you
don't accumulate error if you use if you
use an ellipsoid algorithm the ellipsoid
algorithm you can show has is an epsilon
squared Sigma squared so Sigma is your
additive Gaussian error and epsilon is
the fraction of points that are
corrupted so basically putting this
together tells you that if you use I HT
plus ellipsoid then you're guaranteed to
have this many errors so for example
what this shows is that if you have no
additive error then you get perfect
recovery so so in other words what that
says is if I have linear equations and
then you come and add arbitrarily
corrupted linear equations so Sigma is 0
epsilon is not 0 then if you do
iterative hard fresh holding with your
lips Toit algorithm you get perfect you
get perfect recovery so you can deal
with with sparse but sorry you can you
can solve linear equations with a
constant fraction of corruptions and
recover exactly the solution and that on
the other hand if you if your error is 0
then this is the result that you would
basically expect this kind of
pendants on Sigma then the final slide
is that for for your the filtering
algorithm isn't is order D faster and
you pay the price that we have no a
worse dependence on epsilon the previous
dependence on epsilon is is the best
possible that you can hope for there are
some lower bounds that have showed that
but this is still good enough to get you
exact recovery if you're in the for
example in the linear and the linear
equation case so thanks very much
that's a there